il
[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau d'antenne et
date à dire nous allons passer cette
émission avec marion maréchal elle a été
la plus jeune député de l'histoire de
france elle avait 24 ans elle en a
maintenant 31 retirer de la politique
active elle dirige l'isepp une école
privée de sciences politiques à lyon et
le centre d'analysé et de prospective
qui lui est désormais attaché bonjour
marion maréchal merci d'avoir accepté
mon invitation on va parler politique
mais pas de politique politicienne on va
pas parler de l'actualité ni des
prochaines élections
c'est ce que vous pensez qui m'intéresse
c'est pourquoi vous le pensez mais
d'abord pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
entré en politique rien ne vous y oblige
et dans une génération de l'open ya du
monde tout le monde ne fait pas de la
politique mais la plupart n'en font pas
pourquoi vous alors déjà je tiens à vous
remercier pour ça me fait très plaisir
de ne pas parler du coc vide voilà
sachets d'eau déjà c'est bon je suis
ravi d'être à cette émission et ne pas
parler du coc ville mais ça me change
deuxièmement alors oui vous avez raison
en effet nous sommes neuf petits enfants
côté maternel et la plupart d'entre eux
ne font pas de politique ne sont pas
engagés et où ne sont pas militants du
tout voire n'ont pas les mêmes idées
politiques donc comme quoi on reste une
famille très libre de ce point de vue là
c'est vrai que moi j'ai été engagé jeune
à l'époque au front national des mets
des mes 17 ans et puis j'ai transformé
cet engagement militant en engagement
électoral je dois vous l'avouer
d'ailleurs l'histoire est connue donc je
vais vous l'a répété aujourd'hui mais un
peu d'une force et c'est pas le terme
mais en tout cas on m'a mis le prier et
le pied à l'étrier sans que je le
réclame puisqu'à l'époque j'avais
commencé c'est vrai une première
expérience aux élections régionales à
l'époque deux ans avant les législatives
bon sur une liste en tant que non
éligible voulant faire partie d'une
équipe mais dans l'anonymat si je puis
dire alors c'était un échec je dois vous
l'avouer parce que ça n'est pas passé
inaperçu et j'ai été tout de suite
projetés sur sur les plateaux sans
nécessairement m'y attendre et puis
c'est vrai que deux ans après mon grand
père jean marie le pen est venu me voir
et m'a dit marion
je passe à l'as pris comme une espèce de
l'uby c'était assez surprenant il faut
que tu ailles laver l'honneur du nom le
pen à carpentras donc sali par cette
affaire sordide de carpentras pour ceux
qui s'en souviennent dans les années 90
et dont qui la met généralement seuls
qui sont donnés c'est ma mission c'était
avant l'été 1981 10 si je me souviens
bien et c'était un cimetière avaient été
profanées et un cimetière juif on avait
accusé à l'époque l'extrême droite voilà
d'ailleurs et le enfin particulier le
front national a tort d'ailleurs est le
même le monsieur dont le corps avait
d'ailleurs été profanées de manière
atroce était adhérent est un militant du
front national d'ailleurs à l'époque ce
qui avait été passé sous silence enfin
bref l'histoire et et sordide et elle a
très largement contribué d'ailleurs à la
diabolisation du mouvement et à partir
de là donc jean marie le pen en effet
m'a donné pour mission si je puis dire
d'aller quelques décennies après laver
ce nom et l'honneur de son dans cette
ère de carpentras avec lesquels je n'ai
pas d'attachés familiales il faut il
faut bien le dire
et c'est vrai que j'ai d'abord dit non
et croyez-moi ce n'est pas très facile
de dire non à jean marie le pen et j'ai
même osé lui dire non plusieurs fois ce
que je crois relève d'un courage quand
même à relever mais au final c'est vrai
qu'il a il avait eu ces paroles bon qui
ont qui ont résonné dans mon esprit de
militantes et de personnes engagées il
m'avait écrit une longue lettre en me
disant mais même si toi marion qui a des
convictions qui est engagée qui est
militante
tu ne montre pas l'exemple d'une
certaine manière à la jeunesse de france
en allant au bout de tes convictions en
ayant le courage de présenter aux
élections
ça veut dire que tu n'es pas une vraie
le pen bon autant vous dire qu'ils
avaient qu'il avait tapé juste et je
pars donc à ces élections alors il est
vrai avec un copain en directeur de
campagne fin de manière très très simple
si je puis dire et je découvre la
politique comme cela et en l'occurrence
personne n'imaginait que je puisse être
élu il faut bien le dire ça paraissait
inimaginable à l'époque est bon un
concours de circonstances font que je
suis élu grâce entre autres choses un au
maintien à l'époque de la candidate de
gauche et je suis j'arrive donc à 22 ans
à l'assemblée nationale et donc c
c'est à dire une histoire un peu un peu
atypique je ne pense pas que par moi
même spontanément je me serais lancé
avant deux ans dans une élection
législative ça me paraissait tout à fait
inatteignable et déraisonnable à
l'époque et mais alors qu'en cinq ans
plus tard vous avez renoncé à toutes vos
demandes à moi je me suis dit elle a
envie de réfléchir au fond quand on fait
de la politique quand on est à
l'assemblée nationale peut être qu'on
n'a pas le temps de réfléchir et
particulièrement quand on est jeune ça
vous manque alors ce qui est vrai c'est
que mon moi j'ai été élu très jeune j'ai
passé mes examens de droit alors même
que j'avais été élu député donc j'étais
étudiante encore bons mots je j'ai été
élu et donc c'est vrai que je n'avais
pas eu d'expérience professionnelle et
j'avais toujours espéré et voulu
travailler dans le monde de l'entreprise
notamment créé une moi même une
entreprise et me lancer dans cet univers
de l'entrepreneuriat ça me manquait par
ailleurs je souffrais enfin je craignais
à terme de craindre d'art manque de jeu
craignent à terme pardon de manquer
d'une forme de légitimité
peut-être en gravissant les échelons
petit à petit politique précisément
parce que je n'avais pas eu cette
expérience dans le privé donc ça
m'apparaissait de toute façon important
et puis bon moi j'ai grandi quand même
dans un univers très politique je sais
que voilà il est compliqué de sortir de
la politique que plus on y reste et plus
il est compliqué justement d'en faire le
deuil et je me suis dit voilà marion si
tu ne pars pas maintenant tu ne partira
jamais donc profitez-en
lance toi et c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de quitter mon mandat afin de ne
pas me représenter aux élections
législatives et de démissionner de mon
mandat de conseiller régional afin de
pouvoir mener pleinement cette ville les
opinions politiques on en est très fier
au général on parle de l'élite politique
en particulier disent mes valeurs
mon opinion et c'est en face et souvent
les opinions de sa famille de son milieu
de ses parents de son époque aussi ça
joue beaucoup dans la la bannière qu'on
a de se forger des opinions politiques
dans votre cas vous avez été conditionné
depuis l'enfance puisque vous êtes d'une
famille de politique alors conditionné
je dirais pas ça parce que comme je vous
l'aï dit au début de cette émission on
est neuf petits-enfants et manifestement
tous n'ont pas fait le choix qui a été
le mien et tous n'ont pas d'ailleurs les
mêmes opinions
donc on n'a jamais une ou deux
contraintes quelle qu'elle soit de
d'aller dans le mouvement d'aller à
telle manifestation de penser comme ci
ou comme cela on était une famille très
passionné il y avait beaucoup de débats
à la maison mais tous ne portait pas
exactement les mêmes les mêmes idées et
en l'occurrence je pense vous avez
raison qu'on est tous l'objet de son
héritage et qui a toujours une forme de
transmission dans les familles
transmission même des passions je dirais
c'est presque l'histoire du monde mais
ça ne vient pas que de la politique
on voit ça dans les familles de médecins
on voit ça même dans les familles de
deux journalistes
dans les familles juriste donc ça
m'apparaît pas tout à fait anormale
après c'est vrai qu'on s'approprie cet
héritage on le dépasse on le nuançons le
façonne en fonction de ces expériences
que je pense aussi avoir fait à mon
humble mesure si je puis dire mais c'est
vrai qu'on ne construit pas à partir du
néant c'est totalement utopique
d'imaginer cela
moi je suis aussi pas seulement j'espère
en tout cas mais je suis aussi le
produit en effet de cet héritage
politique et familial et jeux et j'en
suis fier aussi d'une certaine manière
moi j'ai l'impression que vous êtes plus
à droite que jean marie le pen qui lui
même est plus à droite que marine le pen
parce qu'elle a ajouté beaucoup d'aidé
de gauche
hahaha alors est ce que est ce que vous
avez senti de pièces que je me trompe
est-ce que ça va savoir va falloir
m'expliquer cité ce qui est ce que vous
voulez dire par plus à droite que jean
marie le pen mais je marie le pen était
plus libéral que vous tuerez gagnant si
vous voulez marine le pen elle est et
sur les moeurs sur l'économie et plus à
gauche que son père oui je sais pas
alors je me demande s'il ya parfois des
caricatures ou des raccourcis qui sont
faits j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir
renié pour le coup la vision régaliennes
qui a pu être porté par jean marie le
pen pendant que j'attends de voir ce que
va donner moi je dirais gagnant du
centre ronald regan à régalien avec un
pari gagnant
j'ai compris régalien excusez moi comme
on est à distance le
micro me me joue des tours oui donc plus
c'est quoi le par rapport à l'économie
voulait il a eu sa période où il voulait
supprimer l'impôt sur le revenu c'était
très important d'ailleurs à cette époque
là dans le programme du front national
il y avait une vraie carte très libéral
économiquement
oui il ya eu une qu'il ya eu en effet
une époque très très libéral qui a
d'ailleurs succédé une époque où il a
été engagé auprès de pierre poujade qui
en effet été l'ardent défenseur des
commerçants des artisans des tpe face à
la spoliation de l'état donc c'est vrai
que ça a été une période importante je
pense que ça a été une période
d'ailleurs
enfin en tout cas un phénomène assez
généralisé à droite qui pour moi était
une forme de réaction si je puis dire à
l'anticommunisme qui évidemment animé
qui était le moteur d'une grande partie
de cette droite française est d'une
certaine manière ils sont devenus un peu
la caricature à verser de ce qu'ils ont
pu critiquer et donc contre cette vision
socialiste de l'économie très étatiste
il ya eu une forme de réponse al'inverse
qui a considéré qu' à consistait à
vouloir faire la défense d'un
libéralisme parfois un peu et freiner
même alors ce n'est pas le cas de jean
marie le pen je pense en ce qui le
concerne parce que lui a toujours
défendu quand même l'état stratège
l'état l'état régalien
mais pour une certaine droite en tout
cas la défense même d'une forme de néo
libéralisme donc c'est à dire là le la
course à la privatisation notamment des
services publics à la réduction de
l'état régalien à la portion congrue à
la défense du libre échange généralisé
donc la fin d'une politique économique
protectionniste bon je pense que ça
tient une époque on a on a vécu et on a
souffert si on peut dire de des excès de
cette vision néolibérale et donc comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure moi je suis
aussi le le produit d'une époque et
j'arrive à un moment où en tout cas je
me suis engagé à un moment donné où les
leçons les excès de ce néolibéralisme
ont aussi été tirés et donc cette espèce
de vision qui consistait à penser que le
privé
et allez forcément mieux manager ou
mieux géré que le public en toute
circonstance que la privatisation était
forcément la solution que le libre
échange ale forcément conduire à la
prospérité
je pense que j'en suis j'en suis moi
même revenu et je suis plutôt dans une
phase critique de cette vision
néolibérale et donc je considère qu'il y
a des moments où le protectionnisme
selon les pays sont les secteurs peut
être la bonne réponse
la même manière que le libre-échange
selon les secteurs et selon les pays
auxquels ils s'appliquent peut parfois
être la bonne réponse mais en tout cas
il n'a pas il n'y a pas en tout cas je
ne pense pas m'inscrire dans un
dogmatisme idéologique qui consisterait
à vouloir appliquer de manière un peu
mécanique telle ou telle pratique comme
ont pu le faire parfois les grandes
idéologies du du xxème siècle vouloir le
faire les grandes idéologies du xxème
siècle de carbu n'y croyait plus grandes
idéologies parce qu'on a beaucoup dit et
c'est la fin des idéologies moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on vit une époque qui
est plus idéologique que jamais en tout
cas ces grandes idéologies la celle du
20è je pense en grande partie sont
mortes ou en tout cas elles sont en état
de mutation avancé je le voit notamment
dans la jeunesse il n'y a plus oui
malgré tout il ya plus ces grandes
références idéologiques qui donnait
quand même un cadre un imaginaire des
auteurs des réflexions enfin je veux
dire la seule idéologie qu'on pourrait
retrouver aujourd'hui dans la jeunesse
c'est une espèce d'idéologie un peu
liquide qui consiste à vouloir sauver la
planète s'en trouve alors de comprendre
d'ailleurs ce que ça signifie qui
d'ailleurs est et relève moins de la
science politique presque que de la
morale parfois alors même que c'est un
sujet d qui devrait être éminemment
scientifique et technique mais à part
cette idéologie là je ne vois plus dans
la jeunesse de france
voilà des grands cadre structurant avec
des grandes références intellectuelles
qui pourrait leur mettre le pied à
l'étrier d'une certaine construction ou
en tout cas d'un certain d'engagement
politique
j'aimais ce qui est vrai là où je vous
rejoins pardon de la londe et en plus là
où je vous rejoins c'est qu'en revanche
il y a en effet d'autres forme
d'idéologie qui arrive dans le débat
public et qui sont d'ailleurs des
idéologies
très très sectaire très militante j'ai
presque envie de vous dire très
inquiétante je pense notamment à toutes
ces idéologies qui viennent le plus
souvent de la gauche qui sont issus et
transposer des campus américains vers
les universités françaises qu'on appelle
communément scapel en tout cas le
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
l'islamo gauchisme ou en tout cas toutes
ces idéologies qui relève de
l'indigénisme du des colonialismes du du
racialisme d'une certaine manière et qui
aujourd'hui en effet sont en train
d'offrir un nouveau logiciel si je peux
dire à cette gauche ce sont les enfants
monstrueux de sos racisme pour moi d'une
certaine manière des enfants qu'ils qui
qui leur ont échappé et qui sont en
train de tuer le père c'est-à-dire en
train de tuer ce qu'il peut rester de la
gauche républicaine et universaliste
j'arrêterai là après les comparaisons
avec votre famille c'est la dernière je
vous le promets mais j'ai l'impression
que marine le pen à plus d'ambition
politique dans avait jean marie le pen
qui à mon avis n'a jamais été au pouvoir
et n'a jamais eu véritablement l'envi
d'y être je pense que marine le pen elle
a vraiment une vocation à vouloir
conquérir le pouvoir et j'ai
l'impression que vous alors vous l'avez
encore moins d'ambitions peut-être que
jean marie le pen puisque au bout de
cinq ans vous êtes retiré alors on va
voir pourquoi et dans quel but mais mais
voilà je pense que lui de l'aurais
jamais fait il aurait été trop content
de rester
alors je n'ai pas la réponse à cette
question c'est quelque chose que j'ai
souvent entendu que jean marie le pen ne
voulais pas le pouvoir qu'il a tout fait
pour ne pas avoir le pouvoir je
sincèrement je ne sais pas moi
pendant le cadre des conversations
privées qu'on a pu avoir sur le sujet il
m'a jamais dit cela il me l'a jamais
confirmé il ne me l'a jamais confié en
tout cas je ne suis pas tout à fait sûr
qu'ils se soient organisées pour ne pas
avoir le pouvoir
je n'ai pas la réponse à ça je je pense
malgré tout en tout cas pour ceux qui
ont connu le front national des années
80 des années 90 que c'était quand même
une machine extrêmement bien organisé
avec quand même des compétences notable
le groupe parlementaire de 86 qui arrive
à l'assemblée par le biais de la
proportionnelle est un groupe qui est
quand même reconnu pour ses qualités et
ses compétences
donc j'avais j'ai pas le sentiment en
tout cas qu'ils se soient pas donner des
moyens dans son entourage d'avoir des
gens aptes à pouvoir exercer le pouvoir
bon qu'est l'histoire en a voulu
autrement donc ça veut dire quel est le
niveau d'ambition dès le pen selon les
générations je vais avoir du mal à vous
devez une jauge parce que les parcours
sont très différents pour un homme qui
n'avait pas d'ambition qui est parti de
rien qui a construit à un parti en
commençant à 0 75% et qui a construit
une carrière sur 40 ans je trouve que
quand même il a il a fait en tout cas la
démonstration de sa pugnacité s'il n'y
croyais pas du tout ce serait un peu
surprenant bon après ce qui concerne
marine le pen je pense que là pour le
coup on peut pas on peut pas lui enlever
le fait de se donner les moyens ou en
tout cas d'essayer d'arriver aux
affaires ça c'est tout à fait manifeste
et en ce qui me concerne alors peut-être
pouvez-vous mettre ça derrière un manque
d'ambition je ne sais pas en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que
moi j'avais j'avais envie et besoin de
toucher à autre chose et puis parce tout
simplement aussi parce que j'ai goûté
pendant cinq ans on me dirait c'est à la
fois long et court vous avez raison mais
j'ai goûté pendant cinq ans la solitude
du député d'opposition donne inscrit là
malgré la très bonne compagnie de
gilbert collard mais et c'est vrai que
j'avais parfois un sentiment de dignité
c'est un peu fort parce qu'on représente
quand même 20% des français etc
heureusement que l'opposition est là
mais en tout cas je voyais bien que dans
mon travail parlementaire je ne pouvais
pas influé sur ce travail parlementaire
que mes amendements ont été rejetés de
toute façon par principe
quels que soient les arguments que je
puisse déployer et donc c'est vrai qu'au
bout de cinq ans j'ai quand même eu la
conviction que la politique c'était
aussi le combat culturel que ça ne se
faisait pas que par le haut et que ça
faisait aussi par le bas par la société
de manière très concrète et que la
droite au sens large d'ailleurs
souffrait malheureusement de ce manque
d'organisation de réseaux de
d'engagement d'ordre culturel dans la
société et c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu
aussi d'une certaine manière pour suivre
cette forme d'engagement politique d'une
autre manière plus par la voie
électorale mais par par par par
l'engagement éducatif qui est le mien
aujourd'hui alors c'est pas de la
politique au sens partisan du terme
c'est de la politique au sens service à
la cité en essayant de répondre à un
besoin qui est celui aujourd'hui d'une
formation adéquate de nos futures élites
françaises à travers l'isepp
l'impression que vous êtes passés de la
politique à la méta politique
oui c'est cela appeler sam et apolitique
appelé saab cessa combat culturel là
aussi je suis peut-être aussi le produit
de mon époque c'est vrai que pendant
très longtemps le combat culturel a été
d'ailleurs on le voit bien dans à
travers les différents secteurs qui sont
une certaine manière les leviers de
penser dans la société média culture
éducation
la gauche a pendant très très longtemps
était totalement hégémonique il faut
bien le dire elles restent encore
aujourd'hui très largement dominante
bien qu'elle souffre l'arrivée de
quelques voix discordantes aujourd'hui
qu'elle qu'elle vit d'ailleurs très mal
mais il est certain que le modèle
gramsci qui a été cette grande figure du
parti communiste et
italien qui a conceptualisé qui a ce
n'est ces sites et du combat culturel
qui devait précéder le la victoire
politique était plutôt c'est vrai le
l'apanage de la gauche
je pense qu'il y a eu là dessus un
chemin qui a été fait y compris par la
jeunesse de droite peut-être d'ailleurs
au travers de l'engagement de la manif
pour tous j'ai vu cette génération aller
dans la rue
découvrir la nécessité de cet engagement
est presque arrivé trop tard d'une
certaine manière sur ce combat puisque
malgré le million de personnes dans la
rue malgré l'effervescence l'émulation
les réseaux qui ont pu se créer les
jeunes qui ont été formés
ce combat at elle a été au final perdu
et donc on a vu là toute une génération
émerger et alliés ensuite s'engager dans
l'associatif dans les médias voilà et et
prendre conscience que le combat il se
meut mais aussi en amont et dans la
société et dans les esprits et par
l'éducation aussi et pas seulement bas
en aval par les institutions
donc je suis aussi le produit de cela je
pense et d'où la continuité que je vois
ou en tout cas il n'ya l'absence de
rupture qui lie à si je puis dire entre
mon passage à l'assemblée aujourd'hui ce
que je peux faire par le par le biais il
captive toujours une fois de plus sans
être dans une vision dogmatique ou
partisane puisque moi mes étudiants je
suis pas là pour leur apprendre ce
qu'ils doivent penser mais en tout cas
comme une réponse au phénomène
aujourd'hui à la fois d'effondrement du
niveau dans un certain nombre d'écoles
françaises et en parallèle comme réponse
de liberté si je puis dire de pluralisme
au phénomène dont on vient de parler à
l'instant qui est celui d'une d'une wii
de l'arrivée massive militante sectaire
d'idéologie dans les universités dans un
certain nombre d'écoles de grandes
écoles françaises et qui aujourd'hui ne
tolère plus le débat la contradiction et
la liberté d'expression dont beaucoup
d'enseignants sont même eux mêmes les
victimes sans parler des étudiants avec
souvent il faut bien le dire la
complicité ou en tout cas la lâcheté des
directions d'établissement qui sont
totalement à la merci de la pression de
de ces activistes d'extrême gauche c'est
quoi être être de droite pour vous quel
est votre droite vous ont pourrais dire
assez vite mais j'ai l'impression que la
gauche est plus identifié la gauche on
pourrait dire c'est c'est le sait le
progrès c'est l'émancipation
ce serait ça le principal et ceux qui
resteraient encore des valeurs de gauche
encore aujourd'hui en 2021 mais la
droite c'est souvent plus confus pour
vous j'ai l'impression que vous voulez
vous le savez vous oui je pense que
c'est vous avez raison en tout cas je
dirais pas confus je dirais plus diffus
peut-être parce que c'est vrai que la
gauche s'est principalement défini à
travers des penseurs politiques très
très très structuré et très voilà très
très construit très identifié je pense
que la droite c'est un peu plus large
que ça a déjà je verrai ça comme une
forme d'attitude au monde de posture
face au monde dans dans la transmission
dans dans l'héritage dans le goût de la
tradition je pense que la droite c'est
aussi une forme d' imaginaires
d'imaginaire de référence qui sont
d'ailleurs souvent des références plutôt
littéraire et romantique vraiment
politique
bon évidemment il ya des politiques
comme comme tocqueville mais on peut
penser à des balzac
ad chateaubriand voilà qui sont quand
même un peu au coeur au coeur de cet
imaginaire de la droite
je pense qu'il ya il ya aussi malgré
tout des principes politiques il ya des
permanences même si la droite et la
gauche il faut bien le dire selon les
époques ont pu ont pu évoluer dans les
mesures qu'ils ont pu proposer il ya
malgré tout des permanences et parmi ces
permanences on pourrait dire le principe
de subsidiarité par exemple le principe
de subsidiarité qui est censé permettre
à l'individu son plein épanouissement en
le protégeant d'une part de
l'individualisme et d'autre part des
excès éventuelle des pouvoirs publics on
pourrait dire aussi un certain rapport à
la liberté je pense que la liberté de la
gauche c'est une liberté de l'individu
absolue qui se conçoit même au dessus de
la communauté je pense que la liberté
pensé par la droite c'est la liberté de
la personne qui pourrait trouver comme
limite le bien commun de la communauté
et donc oui à la liberté mais la liberté
qui ne qui ne nuit pas si je peux dire à
la communauté qu'elle soit provincial
familiale ou ou nationale d'une certaine
liberté qui s'inscrit dans un cadre donc
vous avez raison c'est oui c'est presque
plus oui c'est ça une forme de deux
postures face au monde je dirais que
véritablement un dogme un dogme bien
arrêtées on dit beaucoup que la france
s'est droitisée audi même que l'extrême
droite certains le disent seraient en
train de gagner la bataille culturelle
justement que cette bataille culturelle
dont vous disiez que la gauche l'avait
longtemps remporté elle était un peu
maître du territoire
est ce que vous le ressentez ça d'abord
cette droitisation de la france et
éventuellement sur le plan culturel
que les les forces sont en train de
changer
bon alors déjà moi je vous lis je réfute
ce terme d'extrême droite parce que je
considère qu'aujourd'hui c'est un terme
qui n'est pas utilisé pour qualifier
c'est un terme qui est utilisé pour
disqualifier en fait c'est un c1 c'est
un slogan c'est voilà c'est une injure
mais ça n'est pas une qualification
politique utilisée à bon escient parce
que je vais pas rentrer dans là dessus
dans le détail de ce qu'est l'extrême
droite mais parmi les deux grandes
définition fait en tout cas critères
qu'on peut retrouver dans l'extrême
droite il ya quand même l'autoritarisme
et l'anti parlementarisme
en ce qui me concerne et je pense
objectivement ce qui concerne le
rassemblement national ce sont deux
critères auxquels nous nous ne répondons
pas donc moi je ne me reconnais pas dans
cette appellation est dans ce terme
d'extrême droite d'une part alors
d'autre part ce qui concerne le combat
culturel
je ne dirais pas que la droite
aujourd'hui au sens large a gagné le
combat culturel c'est aller un peu loin
je crois et je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs que la gauche passe très
largement dominante dans la culture dans
les médias dans l'éducation
la dernière cérémonie des césar ça nous
fait la démonstration dans le monde du
cinéma je pense est en revanche ce qui
est vrai c'est que l
il ya une forme de remise en cause
puisque aujourd'hui certaines voix
dissonantes commencent à apparaître
et d'ailleurs la gauche le vix
extrêmement mal parce qu'elle a eue elle
a tellement eu cette habitude de son
hégémonie qu' il est vrai que dès qu'une
petite voix commencent à apparaître
elle vit ça comme comme véritablement
une remise en question totale de
de son existence mais je crois que
surtout moins qu'une victoire de la
droite c'est surtout l'affaiblissement
de la gauche qui qui se fracasse face au
réel je pense que c'est surtout ça et on
voit bien d'ailleurs je cette cérémonie
des césar elle est intéressante de ce
point de vue là parce que on voit bien
qu'il ya une déconnexion totale entre
une forme de petit microcosme qui voilà
qui va développer
de manière très militante ses lubies en
pleurnichant
et en étant complètement déconnectés des
attentes des français du quotidien des
français ou même de la perception qu'ils
peuvent se faire de l'art et du cinéma
donc donc c'était assez symptomatique si
je puis dire de cette déconnexion et de
ceux de huy de cette disparité entre le
réel et les aspirations d'un petit
milieu qui est de plus en plus
minoritaire mais malheureusement pendant
que vous interrompre marion maréchal on
fait juste une pause on se retrouve
juste après comment l'économie chinoise
at elle résisté à la pandémie de
coronavirus l' empire du milieu est il
le grand gagnant de cette crise la chine
est encore lucide du monde vu que ses
clients sont en récession tous les
produits chinois ne sont pas vendus la
consommation domestique en chine depuis
la crise et la relance de 2007-2008 a
pris le pas sur les autres facteurs de
croissance que la chine soit la première
à repartir c'est une certitude c'est les
premiers à avoir maîtrisé la pandémie
ils ont préféré mettre le paquet sur la
règle de du virus et retrouver des
conditions normales d'activité
économique plutôt que sur des relances
monétaire ou de l'endettement départ
l'espèce de jeu pouvoir pour la
suprématie m'ont dit
la chine à quelques mètres d'avancé sur
ses poursuivants
comment vous jugez vous la situation
aujourd'hui après plus d'un an de crise
le tourisme est probablement l'une des
filières qui souffrent le plus de la
crise sanitaire le tourisme et
l'événementiel c'est à dire en fait tout
ce qui crée des flux de population tout
ce qui crée des rassemblements comment
vous voyez là les possibilités de faire
redémarrer tout ça le rôle des élus en
ce moment qu'ils soient nationaux ou
locaux
c'est de trouver le juste équilibre
entre la protection sanitaire et donc la
disparition du virus interne et la vie
économique et la vie sociale
on voit bien que y'a pas que la vie
économique qui est touché il ya toute la
psychologie des gens c'est trop long
donc il faut ajuster les protocoles
sanitaires à une vie économique
culturelle sportive événementielle qui
puisse renaître
[Musique]
nous reprenons cette émission avec
marion maréchal je reviens sur les
définitions vous avez donné de l'extrême
droite vous avez raison c'est souvent un
terme employé pour disqualifier
mais vous dites que ce qui caractérise
l'extrême droite c'est l'anti
parlementarisme et l'autoritarisme
or ça se répand plutôt pas mal dans la
société française d'aujourd'hui d'être
antiparlementaire de penser que la
représentation politique est disqualifié
qu'elle est méprisable penser qu'il
faudrait davantage d'autorité qu'on
manque d'autorité
là aussi c'est assez bien répandu et on
l'entend même chez nos politiques qu'ils
soient de gauche ou de droite on sent
bien qu'ils peuvent jouer sur ce qu'ils
avaient vu naître la demande d'autorité
des français vous le ressentez pas un
mais je ressens comme beaucoup la
critique du monde politique mais je
crois que ça n'est pas lié en soi au
principe de ce n'est pas une critique de
la représentation ou de la
représentativité si vous voulez c'est
une critique
du du manque pour le coup je pense de
représentativité des idées au sein de
cette assemblée représentative qui n'est
pas tout à fait la même chose
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas le
principe de l'assemblée représentative
qui est mis en cause
c'est le manque de représentativité
autant dire le fait que les gens ont le
sentiment que cette assemblée n'est pas
justement équilibrée entre les
différents courants les différents les
différentes idées qui peuvent traverser
la population française et à juste titre
puisqu'il faut quand même le rappeler
l'assemblée parlementaire française est
la seule qui n'est pas en europe qui
n'est pas élu au sein de l'union
européenne
aux dires par le biais proportionnelle à
l'exception du royaume uni qui lui un
scrutin uninominal majoritaire à un tour
tous les autres pays l'union européenne
ont des formes de proportionnelle pour
pouvoir mettre en place leurs élus et
s'assurer que donc il y avait vraiment
une réelle représentativité
donc on voit bien qu'il ya un sentiment
de de déconnexion finalement entre ces
assemblées et l'état réel de l'opinion
et je pense que cela crée une
frustration cela crée des ressentiments
et si j'ajoute à cela le fait qu'ils
avaient quand même des pratiques
politiques pour le moins discutable par
le passé je pense notamment au fait que
des français et puis par référendum
s'opposer à un certain nombre de
réformes ou d'adhésion à des traités des
traités identiques qui leur ont été
imposées par le biais de l'assemblée
parlementaire
dans la foulée bon il ya un sentiment je
pense de trahison le fait qu'on refuse
de recourir plus régulièrement aussi au
référendum
en tout cas au système de démocratie
directe sur les grands sujets de société
tout cela oui je pense participe d'une
défiance et du fait que les gens ont le
sentiment que l'on bat les élus ne les
représente plus de représente leurs
intérêts je vous demande et tout à
l'heure c'est quoi être de droite pour
vous m'avez très bien répondu mais j'ai
l'impression que ce qui vous caractérise
c'est que très souvent les références de
droite ça remonte alors dans les
générations qui qui nous précèdent un
c'était le gaullisme c'est l algérie
française
ça a été ça avait été vraiment une façon
de se dire de droite en très longtemps
vous j'ai l'impression que ça remonte
beaucoup plus loin j'ai l'impression que
vous puisez même des choses dans
l'ancien régime
est ce que je me trompe ben quoi je
serai fidèle à la tradition de droite
alors en restant dans la chaîne des
temps et on ne comprend pas la chaîne
des temps elle avait moi j'aime pas les
cas si vous voulez mais si je devais
prendre la mesure une référence qui est
assez parlante et je pense qu'ils qui
est assez connue pour qualifier la
droite ou en tout cas les droites
c'était celle de rené rémond et vous
prenez ces trois droites menant à droite
légitimiste la droite bonapartiste la
droite orléaniste qui était censé
catégoriser finalement les différents
courants qui avait pu même parfois
s'opposer à l'intérieur des droites
je pense ne pas être le produit d'un
seul de ces courants mais être un peu
d'une certaine manière la synthèse des
trois comme comme beaucoup de gens
droite c'est à dire que on pourrait
retrouver en effet dans la droite
légitimiste qui était la droite contre
révolutionnaires monarchiste cet
attachement aux provinces à la tradition
à la verticalité au catholicisme mais on
pourrait aussi retrouver dans la droite
bonapartiste d'une certaine manière
l'attachement à la grande france à
l'état fort au réformisme
oh oui même à la démocratie directe
d'une certaine manière qui s'était
manifestée par par le plébiscite
populaire sous napoléon est dans la
droite orléaniste d'une certaine manière
aussi oui bassett cet attachement à la
liberté à à la réforme également au
scientisme à l'innovation
oh que oui ça vient de loin d'une
certaine manière puisque moi je
considère que la france n'est pas née en
donc je j'essaye en plus qu'à par le
biais politique de deux d'être
l'héritière de ce qu'il peut y avoir de
bons de juste de beau dans notre
civilisation qui a été façonné par par
le temps par part patiemment par le
temps et par les générations qui nous
ont précédés et de ne pas tout jeter à
la poubelle dans une forme de
ressentiment
comme c'est trop souvent le cas
aujourd'hui malheureusement on a le
sentiment que l'émancipation passe
nécessairement ça s'est souvent
d'ailleurs le discours de gauche on a le
sentiment que l'émancipation passe
forcément par le fait de faire table
rase du passé et que les héritages passé
sont des contraintes sont des cadres qui
nous empêche de nous accomplir
pleinement
moi je pense mais pas ça je pense qu'on
construit à partir de quelque chose et
qu'on peut le dépasser le transcender
cet héritage mais en revanche pour
pouvoir construire encore faut-il déjà
irrités de quelque chose et d'ailleurs
j'y vois un parallèle avec ceux dont on
parlait tout à l'heure sur ces nouvelles
idéologies venu de la gauche indigéniste
des colonials racialiste c'est à dire
qu'à force de vouloir au nom de
l'émancipation détruire la nation la
tradition la civilisation la religion eh
bien vous vous retrouvez aujourd'hui
avec que la race le sexe ou le genre où
la couleur de peau et pour moi c'est une
régression civilisationnel incroyable
parce que de toute façon l'humain a
besoin d'appartenance il est il est
biologiquement si je puis dire programmé
pour ça et donc si vous lui enlever ses
appartenances qui transcende justement
nos origines et
une couleur de peau que sont notamment
la nation la religion la tradition la
culture et bien vous allez vous
retrouver avec ses appartenances
primaire qui nous qui nous enferme dans
une forme des sciences yayisme c'est une
certaine manière dont qui est la
négation l'émancipation et donc oui je
pense qu'au contraire quand on veut
défendre le l'émancipation de la
personne et qu'on veut défendre la
dignité humaine et bien on a tout
intérêt au contraire à valoriser ce qui
nous permet de nous dépasser de nos
attributs premier va que sont nos
origines où notre sexe voilà pour au
contraire va adhérer à quelque chose de
plus grand et ce qu'il ya de plus grand
ben oui c'est en ce qui me concerne pour
la france bat notre nation française
notre histoire française notre héritage
notre héritage patrick vous croyez en
dieu j'imagine oui tout à fait est ce
que vous croyez que que le christ est
ressuscité
parce que pour moi il ya des entre les
gens qui croient en dieu elle est
catholique et ilia ii il ya 2 2 quand il
ya ceux qui croient que christ est
ressuscité
et puis ceux qui n'y croient pas qu'ils
pensent que c'est une une légende ce
qu'une fariboles vous vous êtes dans
quel camp ah bah non mais moi je suis
catholique donc normalement si je suis
catholique je crois que dieu a
ressuscité en tout cas jésus qui est le
fils de dieu venu sur terre pour nous
sauver donc là dessus oui en effet j'ai
moi ggg la fois j'ai la foi et ma
revanche
j'essaye de faire la distinction je
pense qu'on peut avoir la foi
aujourd'hui tout en étant un fervent
défenseur de la laïcité
je ne fais pas la confusion entre les
deux même si évidemment le fait d'avoir
la foi façonne aussi une forme de vision
du monde c'est et puis probablement
créer aussi un attachement particulier à
l'héritage catholique français qui je
pense fait partie intégrante de notre de
notre identité française elle ne l'est
puisse pas cette identité elle ne la
qualifie pas à elle seule mais elle y
contribue aussi très largement et
renoncer à cela c'est aussi renoncer une
certaine vision du monde parce que le
catholicisme
bon an mal an qu'on soit croyant
d'ailleurs wattez a façonné chez nous à
une certaine vision de l'homme d'une
certaine vision de 7
inité a aussi contribué à façonner nos
institutions
comme des institutions comme le mariage
en sont notamment issus à façonner notre
éducation à façonner même d'une certaine
manière nos territoires puisque les noms
dans nos territoires de nos paroisses
d'une villa gens sont aussi très
largement issue et donc c'est vrai que
ce qui m'effraie dans cette danse est
quand celle culture comme on l'appelle
maintenant dans cette volonté de faire
table rase et de traîner devant les
tribunaux de la morale actuelle tous
ceux qui nous ont précédés
comment dire qu'on les en les mettant
comment dire en les face à eau
comment dire aux données actuelles de
notre morale si je peux dire qu'on remet
pas les choses dans leur contexte mais
on les juge à l'aune finalement de notre
morale actuelle
eh bien je crains qu'en faisant cela on
contribue à détruire ce qu'il reste
encore de notre de notre culture commune
de notre matrice culturelle commune et
je pense qu'il ne peut pas y avoir deux
nations et donc pas de démocratie qui
fonctionne sans qu'il y ait cette
matrice culturelle commune qui nous
donne quand même des références
et une forme de solidarité naturelle
puisque la solidarité j'aime bien si
jamais je trouve cette expression
intéressante quand on prend le légalité
de liberté égalité fraternité
finalement la fraternité c'est la seule
chose qui ne se décrète pas
politiquement la fraternité ça se
ressent c'est un sentiment spontanée
qu'on a à l'égard d'une personne avec
laquelle on a le sentiment de partager
quelque chose et donc et bien pour que
cette fraternité existe pour qu'on ait
envie d'aider son prochain dans la
nation il faut préserver absolument
cette matrice commune et je pense en ce
qui me concerne qu'elle passe aussi par
par cet héritage
catholique c'est pour ça que vous êtes
hostile a priori je pense je crois à la
société multiculturelle je pense que la
société multiculturelle en fait c'est le
terme poli pour dire
la fin de la société occidentale et la
société française parce qu'en réalité
dans cette société multiculturelle c'est
l'effacement de la culture française à
laquelle on est en train d'assister et
en effet je pense que la cohabitation de
différentes cultures sur le territoire
malheureusement abouti très souvent à
des frictions si ce n'est même des
violences des incompréhensions et la
difficulté du coup de se retrouver dans
ce cadre national commun et donc ça
finit dans le cadre démocratique par
faire une forme de guerre de permanente
des minorités où l'on n'est plus capable
de s'accorder sur l'essentiel et ce sont
finalement les minorités les mieux
organisés qu'ils vont réussir le plus
souvent dans le jeu démocratique à faire
la différence par rapport à des
majorités qui se sent de plus en plus
exclus et de plus en plus passive donc
oui je pense que c'est un modèle qui est
acquis est un qui est un mauvais modèle
qui est dangereux pour la cohésion
nationale et qui en plus sous forme de
tolérance en tout cas au prétexte de la
tolérance risque d'aboutir à un modèle
auquel moi je ne veux surtout pas
arriver qui est celui d'une forme
d'apartheid je le voit notamment dans
l'est dans les différentes concessions
qui sont régulièrement a accordé
notamment auprès de certaines
communautés musulmanes le plus souvent
d'ailleurs politisés qui cherche à
obtenir un certain nombre de concessions
au prétexte du respect de leur culture
d'origine ou la religion par exemple les
horaires séparés dans les piscines
ce genre de choses ou des accès réservé
aux femmes à certains moments et on voit
bien que au prétexte de tolérance en
acceptant en bon an mal an ce type de
concession
eh bien on finit en effet par dessiner
une forme de société de l'apartheid ou
et bien aujourd'hui ce sont des horaires
réservés aux femmes dans les piscines et
puis demain se sont littéralement
l'interdiction à ces mêmes horaires pour
d'autres personnes qui sont pas issus de
cette religion de pouvoir y accéder
donc je pense que c'était en effet un
modèle qui est dangereux qui n'est pas
en plus le modèle traditionnel français
pendant des années on a vu à l'oeuvre ce
modèle de l'assimilation fonctionner moi
je crois en la simulation je pense qu'on
peut être un français d'origine
étrangère et être pleinement français
pleinement citoyen france
encore faut-il que les étals exige de
vous et encore faut-il pour s'assimiler
s'assimiler non seulement à quelqu'un
c'est à dire encore faut-il être en
contact avec ce peuple historique qui
est le porteur finalement de cette
culture
ce qui malheureusement est de moins en
moins le cas dans un grand nombre de
territoires français et encore faut-il
s'assimile à quelque chose donc encore
faut-il que l'état où le gouvernement et
le peuple lui-même assume d'avoir une
culture qu'ils soient singulière une
culture spécifique et d'en déterminer
d'une certaine manière en tout cas très
largement les contours et surtout les
points non négociables pour que les
personnes qui arrivent sache à quoi s'en
tenir et il ne s'enferme pas finalement
dans des dents des revendications
communautaires néanmoins on peut avoir
une autre religion que la religion
catholique traditionnelle légalement
c'est ce tract dans notre pays on est
bien d'accord
évidemment évidemment évidemment non
mais bien tout à fait d'ailleurs
l'assimilation telle qu'elle s'est
opérée n'a jamais obligé les gens à
changer de religion ou à ou à se
convertir au catholicisme loin s'en faut
mais simplement ont réservé la pratique
de sa religion aux sphères privées on
n'en faisait pas un outil politique de
propagande politique et on ne cherchait
pas à l'imposer au quotidien à
l'ensemble des français ou dans la
sphère publique en général et je pense
que ça m'apparaît être là l'exercice
d'équilibré le plus efficace pour
conserver l'harmonie dans la dans la
société
et qu'est ce que vous reprochez la
mondialisation des échanges
est-ce que c'est véritablement votre
génération ça vous avez grandi dans un
pays la france traversée par les
influences des after the multiple est
dans un monde où les frontières sont
beaucoup moins rigide qu'elle ne l'était
autrefois alors vous avez l'air de le
regretter
justement mai mais j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi la mondialisation en soit c'est
un c'est un état de fait enfin je veux
dire ça pour le coup c'est pas c'est pas
une politique la mondialisation le fait
que les échelles ce soir et récits que
les moyens de transport nous a permis de
pouvoir se déplacer plus vite sur des
distances plus longues
la multiplication des échanges les
moyens de télécommunication tout ça
c'est un état de fait
évidemment il n'est pas question de de
pouvoir supprimer tout cela plus que
c'est le monde dans lequel on vit en
revanche ce qui pose une problématique
ce serait plutôt l'idéologie du
mondialisme ou de la globalisation c'est
à dire que ce qu'on met derrière cela le
plus souvent c'est en effet l'abolition
des frontières qu'elle soit d'ailleurs
des frontières humaines ou des
frontières économiques au prétexte que
cette libéralisation totale des échanges
entraînerait une forme de prospérité
générale dans lequel l'ensemble des pays
se retrouverait qui est d'ailleurs
souvent le corollaire d'une autre vision
qui a été porté pendant très longtemps
par par l'om sait qui est celle de la
division internationale du travail c'est
à dire que d'une certaine manière chaque
pays devait avoir une spécialité
économique
en ce qui concerne la france bon bah on
a pu imaginer
on aurait pu imaginer le tourisme les
jardins bio les services et l'économie à
très haute valeur ajoutée admettons
c'est en tout cas le chemin qui a été
pris ces dernières années et que
finalement les pays dans leur
complémentarité pourrait ainsi échanger
et et bénéficier chacun d'aider des
bénéfices de la mondialisation
on a bien vu les limites à l'occasion de
cette crise du coronavirus de cette
logique et on voit bien qu'une nation
pour pouvoir être résiliente
c'est-à-dire pour pouvoir encaisser un
certain nombre de chocs en situations de
carence de manque de pénurie ou de
difficultés a besoin malgré tout de
pouvoir assurer un certain nombre de
secteurs stratégiques essentiels parmi
lesquels le secteur industriel qui a en
plus le mérite d'avoir des gains de
productivité importants dont être
pourvoyeur de richesses et d'emplois
et il est vrai que dans ses stratégies
de l'abolition totale des frontières
on voit bien qu'il ya de grandes
difficultés à pouvoir conserver un
appareil industriel
dans de bonnes conditions s'ajoute à
cela évidemment des particularités
françaises
sur le plan de la complexité du droit du
travail de l'instabilité législative de
bondir de niveau de taxation et d'impôts
qui évidemment contribuer également à
nuire à la compétitivité mais en tout
cas c'est vrai qu'il ya une forme de
bilan aujourd'hui qui est fait de ce
libre échange et qui aujourd'hui remis
remis très largement en questions
auxquelles s'ajoutent bien sûr les
frontières humaines et là où on voit
bien je sais pas si on aura le temps
d'en rentrer dans le détail mais on voit
bien évidemment que ce mythe aussi de
l'abolition des frontières est aussi un
vecteur malheureusement d'aggravation de
la pauvreté en france et de l'insécurité
la pauvreté parce qu'évidemment
l'immigration telle que nous la vivons
aujourd'hui est principalement une
immigration à bas niveau
socioprofessionnel et principalement
familial et donc qui malheureusement
contribue à augmenter la plupart du
temps à là fois le chômage est donc
évidemment le poids sur les finances
publiques et insécurité parce que
malheureusement un certain nombre de
terroristes islamistes sont passés ont
utilisé les failles finalement de ce
système sans frontières pour pouvoir se
glisser et frappé la france est et tué
des français sans parler évidemment
derrière de l'immigration clandestine
qui elle aussi est un pourvoyeur
d'insécurité les chiffres notamment sur
les mineurs isolés ou en tout cas les
dix mineurs isolés en ile-de-france qui
serait responsable de près de 40% des
chiffres de l'insécurité en
ile-de-france en est la démonstration
j'aimerais savoir marion maréchal qui a
la vision que vous avez 2 2 de la
société en tout cas de la société que
que vous souhaiteriez est ce qu'elle est
guérard chic ou égalitaire mais je pense
que la hiérarchie comme égalitaire de me
demander si je veux remettre en place un
système de castes
non non non mais on peut penser que on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
société déjà hier arctique ont fait très
souvent la différence et l'opposition
même entre les élites et le reste du
peuple
on peut considérer qu'on est aujourd'hui
dans une visée dans une société déjà
hiérarchisé et et qu'on voudrait qu'elle
le soit davantage ou au contraire qu'on
voudrait qu'elle le soit moins et ce
moment la plus égalitaire mais moi je le
déplore tout à fait mais problème c'est
que si vous voulez je pense que
l'égalité elle passe d'abord par
l'égalité des chances c'est ça on se
présente ça commencement comme un slogan
mais c'est ça le coeur de l'égalité
l'égalité c'est pas de chercher à
imposer par la force
le fait que tout le monde soit
à égalité le plus souvent des ans
niveler par le bas parce que ça son
c'est utopique et la plupart de temps
malheureusement quand on cherche à créer
une égalité artificielle elle se fait on
rit on le voit bien le plus souvent par
le bas c'est d'ailleurs souvent le
résultat auquel arrive la gauche
je pense que la première dès la première
d égalité à laquelle il faut parvenir
c'est l'égalité des chances à venir le
fait aujourd'hui qu'on ne soit pas
assignée à résidence sociale c'est à
dire quand on est fils d'ouvriers dans
la creuse eh bien on puisse avoir la
chance un jour ce par son travail par
son engagement d'obtenir peut-être accès
à des grandes écoles est évidemment de
pouvoir progresser sur l'échelle sociale
or aujourd'hui ce qui est vrai c'est que
cet ascenseur social il est brisé
il est brisé parce que l'éducation
nationale notamment ne tient plus ses
promesses malheureusement il suffit de
regarder les classements internationaux
dans les différentes matières pour s'en
convaincre
ce qui entraînera d'ailleurs
probablement le sacrifice de notre école
de grandes écoles de mathématiques d'ici
20 ans de nos scientifiques de nos
médecins et qui contribuera probablement
d'ailleurs au déclassement de la france
si rien n'est fait face à la montée en
puissance de pays comme la chine comme
l'inde comme la russie qui produisent
des médecins des ingénieurs de plus en
plus de plus en plus talentueux donc ça
pour vous dire que l'égalité elle passe
d'abord par ça et c'est à cette promesse
pour le coup qui est une une promesse
républicaine mais pas que et une
promesse qui n'est qui n'est plus tenu
ça c'est tout à fait certain et vous
avez raison de le dire nous vivons dans
une société fracturée
à mon avis il ya différentes fractures
d'ailleurs qui s'amoncellent les unes
sur les autres
les fractures territoriales ça a été dit
souvent ça a été théorisée par notamment
des sociologues comme jérôme fourquet
met donc la périphérie contre contre la
métropole les gagnants contre les
perdants de la mondialisation la
campagne contre la ville si je puis dire
c'est qu'il va j'existe et je pense
notamment que je pense néanmoins que le
rôle du politique
ça n'est pas de les aggraver en faisant
de la politique catégorielles c'est à
dire en utilisant une forme de parts de
marché qui consisterait à vouloir parler
prioritairement à tel ou tel strates de
la société au détriment de l'autre ce
qui est malheureusement souvent fait
aujourd'hui dans le discours politique
ou dans l'action politique mais au
contraire de
de d'essayer de briser ces clivages de
les dépasser 2 les amoindrir et de ne
surtout pas du coup jouer les
territoires les uns contre les autres
et malheureusement ce n'est pas le
chemin que qu'ils aient pris je suis
d'accord avec vous moi je pense que la
lingue l'une des solutions aux maux
français c'est d'avoir une stratégie sur
les 20 à 30 ans à venir sur les villes
moyennes
c'est à dire de ne plus tout tabler sur
les métropoles comme c'est souvent le
cas aujourd'hui quand on regarde les
parts d'investissements qui sont
consacrés de sortir de l'imaginaire qui
consisterait à penser que la métropole
est un lieu d'innovation ce qui est
démenti la plupart du temps par les
chiffres
c'est cette fameuse théorie des classes
cléa créative vous savez qu'il faut
attirer dans les métropoles je pense que
le l'égalité française vers l'égalité
des territoires l'égalité de l'accès à
l'emploi de l'accès à l'université elle
se fera d'abord pas un nouveau maillage
territorial et par le biais de ces
villes moyennes qui aujourd'hui sont en
train d'être aspirés par les métropoles
alors même qu'elles ont encore de
l'actif
elles ont des infrastructures elles ont
des talents elles ont encore pour
certaines des universités donc d'arrêter
ce phénomène d'aspiration et au
contraire de réinvestir et de re table
et sur ses villes moyennes pour
retrouver cette france des 100 des 200
villes moyennes qui a fait longtemps
notre prospérité et vous sentez plutôt
libertaire ou autoritaires vous même je
parle en tant que politique a pas dans
votre vie de tous les jours bien entendu
et oui je sais pas tu nous tiens c'est
une question très déplacé mais non alors
tout dépend ce que vous mettez alors
parce que c'est toujours pareil personne
ne met la même chose derrière ces mots
et derrière ces notions donc tout dépend
ce que vous mettez derrière le terme de
libertaire parce que lille et les
libertariens aux etats unis c'est
quelque chose de très partagée dans
liège entend libertaire déroutant c'est
que chacun doit pouvoir vivre le plus
librement possible
vous êtes du côté des libertés
individuelles notamment dans les moeurs
et comportements c'était plus
autoritaire c'est quelqu'un qui pense
qu'à un moment il faut que la l'intérêt
général la collectivité son mot à dire
ah ben moi je ne suis absolument pas
pour influer sur la vie privée des gens
et je
je souhaite à ce que chacun reste libre
de ses moeurs et de sa vie mais je pense
qu'après la politique c'est aussi un
équilibre en effet entre la défense des
libertés individuelles et des libertés
fondamentales qui sont aujourd'hui notre
bien précieux largement malmené par
cette crise il faut il faut bien le dire
et en même temps la défense de l'intérêt
général ce qu'on peut aussi appeler le
le le bien commun c'est à dire de faire
en sorte que la défense de ses libertés
individuelles ne se transforme pas en
droit tyrannique et que ces droits
tyrannique ne s'applique pas au
détriment précisément de la sécurité de
la cohésion et l'harmonie nationale
en tout cas de nos goûts de nos
communautés naturelles dont nous avons
besoin pour vivre pour nous développer
pour nous émanciper pour être éduqué et
pour pour grandir donc bon je dirais que
je suis ni libertaire ni autoritaire je
pense que ces deux catégories soit un
peu statique pour qu'on puisse se mettre
pour qu'on puisse se mettre dedans
en tout cas c'est sûr que je ne ne
communie pas à l'individualisme qui
aujourd'hui est un peu le le ciment
malheureusement nos sociétés actuelles
d'une certaine manière on aurait l'état
et l'individu seul face à l'état et il
n'y aurait plus c'est que ces corps
intermédiaires qui je pense sont des
décors utile pour le développement de
l'individu et je pense évidemment à la
famille je pense aux communautés
professionnelles mais je pense aussi aux
provinces et on recoupe d'ailleurs ce
qu'on ne jette alors sur la subsidiarité
je pense qu'il est important d'avoir des
niveaux de décisions adaptées selon
selon le sujet politique dont on parle
et l'identité il nous reste qu'une
minute alors ça paraît un peu court mais
l'identité est une valeur aujourd'hui je
pense que c'en est une pour vous mais ce
n'est pas une c'est pas une valeur
l'identité identité cc comment verser
quelque chose de charnel
c'est pas c'est pas une valeur qu'on
décrète à laquelle on adhère ou on
n'adhère pas on la vit d'identité c'est
ce qu'ils oublient à philly fils ce qui
nous définit si on si on renonce à son
identité
bon ben on renonce
on renonce à ce qu'on est d'une certaine
manière donc moi je pour moi d'une
certaine heure c'est pas une option
c'est ça ça s'impose ça s'impose
d'autant plus par les temps qui courent
on peut dire on peut considérer que son
identité n'est pas ne vient pas de ses
racines de sa religion du pays dans
lequel on est né on peut dire que son
identité on cela forge au fil du temps
elle serait qu'elle serait non je crois
que je je crois pas je pense que dans
l'identité
il ya une part de 2 d'héritage il ya une
part d'inné il ya une part de reçus qui
s'impose je sais que c'est insupportable
aujourd'hui aux oreilles des
individualistes que d'imaginer qu'ils
aient une part de deux choses qui nous
échappent mais je pense que l'identité
elle se reçoit aussi alors elle se
déplace à près par sa vie par son
expérience par ses engagements mais elle
se reçoit aussi on est tous le produit
de notre histoire de nos traditions de
notre culture et l'identité c'est un peu
aussi tout ce que vous avez dit ça n'est
pas que ça mais c'est aussi ça il je
pense que c'est une c'est une bonne
chose parce que dans cet héritage et
dans cette identité
on a reçu des choses une fois de plus
qu'ils ont été façonnés par ceux qui
nous ont précédés des belles choses des
choses justes ddd sagesse des actifs des
acquis du capital et que tout ça bien
soyons reconnaissants de l'avoir faisons
le fructifier
plutôt que de jouer les mauvais enfants
qui ne veulent pas avoir de comptes à
rendre à personne
merci mario match elle doit passer toute
cette émission avec nous et
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m